c'est une des artères principales de
guyancourt le mail des sols a connu une
période de rénovation une nouvelle voie
piétonne de nouvelles plantations des
espaces de jeux pour les enfants un
projet municipal lancée en 2014
je trouve que c'est vraiment une très
belle rénovation parce que nous habitons
depuis 30 ans dans le quartier donc on a
reconnu l'ancien mal my vraiment je
trouve que c'est très réussi
j'aime beaucoup cet endroit parce que je
trouve que c'est aéré pour les enfants
je trouve que c'est une bonne idée est
effectivement d'abord rassembler les
deux chemins qui était avant de part et
d'autre en un sol fait plus de
luminosité et plus de déplacements doux
au faciles sont sans gêne sans rien du
tout
l'idée de ce projet remplacer les saules
malades datant des années 70
le chantier a commencé en juillet 2018
deux entreprises et leurs sous-traitants
travailler sur leurs vêtements et les
plantations
dix sept mille mètres carrés de surface
réaménager un investissement de plus de
2 millions d'euros pour guyancourt cette
voie verte qui permet la cohabitation
entre les piétons les cyclistes les
familles avec poussettes
donc c'est c'est avant tout ce
revêtement aussi en granit d'excellente
qualité
et puis effectivement ces espaces verts
qui ont été recréés avec énormément
d'essence nouvelles et notamment des
essences de sol le long du mall on
retrouve des saules donc des grands sol
en taille très importante puisque
certains font sept mètres de haut au
final ce projet a abouti à travers des
concertations avec les riverains
une concertation justifiée par la
contestation de certains habitants à
propos de l'abattage des arbres